[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
old pirates yes there are by
sought out to the merchant ships
minutes after they took eye
from the bottomless pit
but my
hand was made strong
by the end of the almighty
we flower in this generation
triumphantly
so won't you help the same
these songs of freedom
cause all i ever have
[Applause]
redemption song
[Music]
emancipate yourself from mental slavery
none but ourselves can free our minds
have no fear for atomic energy
none of them can stop the time
how long will they kill our brothers
while we stand aside and look
some say it's just a part of it
we've got to fulfill the book
so won't you help to sing
these songs of freedom
is all i ever had
[Music]
[Applause]
redemption song
yeah all i ever
[Music]
had redemption zone
[Music]
[Applause]
emancipate yourself from mental slavery
none but ourselves can free our minds
have no fear for atomic energy
as none of them can stop the time
how long will they kill our brothers
while we
stand aside
and look
some say it's just a part of it
you've got to fulfill the book
i want your help to sing
these songs of freedom
cause all i ever had
[Music]
redemptions
[Music]